on february 13th the batman director
Matt Reeves took to Twitter to share the
first camera test for the upcoming
comic-book adaptation in which Robert
Pattinson plays The Dark Knight it
doesn't show very much a Pattinson space
but what the video lacks in direct
FaceTime it makes up for in epic slow
motion pans a Pattinson fat man suit the
clip is soaked in red light and begins
with Pattinson walking toward the camera
as it focuses on the bat insignia on his
costume as he turns to one side we get a
peek of the shoulder pieces of the new
suit and a taste of the baton sand cape
then finally the lower half of Pattinson
space comes into focus with the upper
half shielded by his Batman mask given
the day it was dropped and it's candy
red color palettes the first video of
Patton since Batman could be considered
something of a Valentine's Day present
from Reeves and the folks at Warner
Brothers pictures from our vantage point
it looks as though the film's team may
have been inspired by a few different
versions of Batman's iconic suit when
they were working on the design for the
new movie the short video Matt Reeves
released shows a mechanical looking
Batman logo in the 2015 video game
Batman Arkham Knight the bat suit armor
pieces would mechanically tighten a line
or separate depending on what Batman
wanted to do Arkham origins also
featured several different shoulder
armor options for the Batman suit that
looks similar to what's shown in the
camera test clip Reeves shared online in
Batman Gotham Knight the 2008 anthology
film comprised of animated superhero
shorts
Batman rocked a popped collar and a chin
guard in the crossfire segment finally
and Gotham by gas lights an alternate
reality Batman set in the late 1880s
also wore a slightly popped collar while
battling against Jack the Ripper there's
even a theory going around that the
Batman insignia on the new suits is
literally made from pieces of the gun
that killed Bruce's parents so that's
metal regardless of how the costume came
together and what pieces have passed
Batman media it might be referencing the
important thing is that Pattinson loves
how it looks
speaking with Yahoo Entertainment on
October 2019 Pattinson briefly gushed
about his bat suit mattis got a really
awesome idea about it I think this thing
is going to be very very cool luckily
for everyone involved in the Batman
reactions to the first camera test the
Pattinson in his bat suits have been
overwhelmingly positive comic-book coms
Brandon Davis wrote in response to
Reeves his tweet it's beautiful
youtuber and podcast Oh
Eddie Purbeck was so impressed with the
video that a espera Reeves his hand in
marriage
writing Matt will you marry me after
watching the camera test the Pattinson
his Batman
Awards ace editor-in-chief Eric Weber
tweeted can we magically make it 2021
finally real bland podcast co-host Kevin
McCarthy had a simple message for Reeves
thank you sir
hell yes fans have reacted similarly
tweeting out gifts of people screaming
with glee and straight up yelling to
express just how happy they were with
the test footage when user tweeted
thank you Matt Reeves I was like legit
dying for Batman news yes let's freakin
go another road Matt Reeves I owe you my
life this is magnificent thank you thank
you thank you
yet another fan was particularly
intrigued by the finer details of the
suits what role at buy play in the
upcoming film and the prospect of how
the costume would hold up over the
course of the Batman and Beyond the
textures the stitches it's amateur it's
handmade has just passed the beginning
of the bat it's so beautiful I can't
imagine how the suit is going to damage
evolved through the course of the movies
it's plain to see people are get illipe
icking up on what Reeves is putting down
even though the Batman is still
incredibly far out from its June 25th
2021 release dates this first look at
Robert Pattinson version of the
character promises even better things to
come as the film gets closer to theaters
we can't wait to see what the new
version of Gotham City looks like
city this city is a labyrinth designed
to mock me
expectations are high and the standard
is now set we officially can't wait to
meet the Batman check out our newest
video right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]